un nouveau départ pour le conservatoire
de créteil catherine trautmann est venu
inaugurer les nouveaux locaux et à cette
occasion elle a annoncé que créteil
serait dorénavant érigé en conservatoire
national des régions une superbe
promotion pour cet organisme qui doit
maintenant s'enraciner dans le tissu
urbain
reportage benoît du but l'air et pierre
brasse caisse c'est comme un grand
rideau de scène qui s'est ouvert dans la
cité un lieu de spectacle tant que
d'enseignement dédié à marcel dadi
gourou de plusieurs générations
d'apprentis guitariste cette
architecture lumineuse et habitait
depuis quelques semaines par la musique
le conservatoire quitter la bohème des
préfabriqués et bien chantez maintenant
l'art lyrique est un des piliers de
l'activité du conservatoire qui devient
producteur de spectacles 1 carmen est
programmée pour février avec l'opéra qui
réunit tous les arts de la scène avec
ses nouveaux locaux avec le classement
promis en conservatoire national de
région
le directeur estime avoir enfin les
moyens de son ambition ouvrir les portes
de la grande musique à la population des
prêts tél
s'agit effectivement d'un tournant
puisque la ville de créteil a fait le
pari courageux à la fois difficile et
passionnant d'installer son
conservatoire dans une zone sensible
donc et notre objectif est de tisser des
liens avec les jeunes de ces quartiers
tout en conservant la qualité
d'enseignement d'écran internationale le
fipd pour conservatoire c'est pour
bientôt et en attendant l'ouverture de
l'atelier de danses urbaines les enfants
du quartier viennent avec l'école les
classes à horaires aménagés
c'est la possibilité d'accéder à un
enseignement musical approfondie pour
des enfants motivés
j'ai passé le test
j'aime beaucoup la musique c'est pour ça
que j'ai essayé ça me fait plaisir de
chanter comme ça le fun la musique comme
ça après ben je te montrer dé quoi je
sais faire et sa vie faire l'an prochain
les enfants chanteront pour le
centenaire de francis poulenc en
harmonie et en public